this person like I said as a long time
member of the Meetup runs her own Meetup
um long you know good member of the
community but in an alternate life being
a hack and hacker she would have been an
electronic musician a DJ and a sailor
please welcome Chris
[Music]
hey everybody
how are you
okay
you weren't expecting me
um well my name is Chris Wu and like
Jared said I've been a member of this
community gosh since like 2009-ish
um but you know uh I'm glad to see all
of you and I am here to talk about I'm
doing the friend of data science talk
and here to talk with you about how to
win friends and influence product
managers because that's the thing that
I've been spending my time on lately so
um before we dive in I wanted to set
some context because I know today has
very much been about like being a
practitioner of data science this is not
that talk
um this is this is a talk that's kind of
like data science proximate but I wanted
to make clear that yeah it's not going
to be a technical talk you're not going
to see statistics you're not going to
see charts
um but also uh it's informal wait why am
I not seeing what I'm expecting ah here
we go um but but the information in
getting you is informed by evidence
experience and opinions and because its
opinion and you know like your
experience of having worked with product
people might be different from mine but
that said like I hope that you will keep
an open mind as I speak and maybe uh you
know if nothing else just like see a
different side of what the relationship
is like so
um so moving on uh UE hold a few things
to be self-evident truths number one
culture is localized so the things that
I have experienced over the course of my
career might be a little bit different
from yours and even in your own
experience you know as you move from
like company to company or people change
you might notice that like you know what
was true before you know about like
culture and people and relating to
people becomes different over time so I
just wanted to make that point and then
the second thing is that people are
random so even though a lot of data
science is about deriving insights from
analytics or data right there's always
something unexpected that happens and
the same is true when you're interacting
with a product person you might you know
generally like for me personally I try
to be as consistent as possible but
every once in a while I surprise people
so uh that said because of these two
things your mileage may vary with regard
to what I'm about to share with you
so there is a goal here all of that said
which is I'm aiming to be give you a
useful information
Okay so
I think if you take nothing else away
from my talk today just know this that
successful pming in my view is all about
persuasion
and that persuasion comes from that
combination of deep empathy for the
customer
the ability to bring evidence to any uh
any stance or decision that a PM might
want to make and also
um you know understanding the people
that you're talking with so one thing
that I don't hear people who speak very
much about in these kinds of like you
know what does a PM do and how do you
work with a PM is understand who that PM
stakeholders are
so
persuasion
okay so another thing that you might
want to think about as well is you know
any business is usually driven by some
underlying motivation of like one of the
Builder functions
so what do I mean by that
is it an engineering-led company
something like a Google is it a
design-led company something like an
Airbnb or might it be a product-led
company something kind of like a slack
or maybe an air table if you know what
this is and you and your PM see eye to
eye you are on your way to forming a
very powerful Alliance together so what
does that Alliance look like and this is
again from my view and my experience and
what I've observed having crowdsourced
part of this talk too is is this when
you're working with a PM you always the
PM is always thinking about the customer
right and if you're working with uh you
know other people in the business they
might be too but you're as a PM your
responsibility is to think about the
customer but you're also going to be
thinking about the business so things
like you know how do we increase
adoption and growth and retention and
then expansion
these are some of the factors that like
all of the thinking revolves around and
if you can assist in any of these ways
again strong Alliance and you can start
to influence too
um the other thing another thing that
PMS are very responsible for is
evidence-based decision making now that
evidence can come in numbers but it can
also come through like a qualitative
feedback too and if you work on that
um particularly now with so many tools
that are doing sentiment analysis and
topic extraction and just kind of like
trying you know ability that ability to
synthesize information these are very
very powerful tools that you have in
your toolkit that you can use to partner
with your product manager
you also wanted the product manager is
also responsible for prioritization in
most companies and what that means is
like you know there's like a million
things that you could be doing right
there's a million ways to be thinking
about how do you get that adoption that
growth that retention that expansion but
ultimately the pm has a responsibility
to make sure that the cross-functional
team that works with them is being
applied well in a way that delivers
value to the business and that means you
have to make trade-offs and you have to
prioritize and again your insights can
help with that
and finally the last thing that I would
say here is that you want to be you know
developing lots of testing or developing
lots of tests and or testing of
hypotheses you want to be able to
predict the future and finally you want
to back it was just all of those
decisions with evidence does this make
sense so far
and does it seem familiar
if it's new
we're going to keep going
so another thing that I want to share
with you is that like because all of
this really comes down to people you
want to be speaking the same language as
your product partner
sorry
so
okay so everything that I have to share
here will just kind of like talk it
through
so you want to be defining some of the
terms of art or some of the terms that
the two of you are going to be using and
also start to figure out what those
factors within those terms are
so those include hang on
safety blanket
so those include well I can't I find
this
so so those include the terms like
impact an impact at least in my what
what I'm seeing right now like
everybody's talking about impact right
right but what is that formula and how
what you know what is it that's
important and what goes into figuring
out that formula for impact you want to
be also talking about success right
everybody has a different definition of
success in everything that you do
together you want to be thinking about
what that definition is and what goes
into it and then you can start to help
build you can start build those models
and build new models too if you are
seeing something and you understand
what's on the PM's mind who the
stakeholders are and how these things
are defined you can start to influence
the roadmap
and the last thing that comes up a lot
but you have to find how do I put this
you you have to find like a friendly way
to ask those questions like how do we
know
if we have any sorts of evidence or
rationale that existed before you
started partnering with your product
partner you you're going to want to know
what that is and figure out how do we
how did we know
because things change people are random
situations change
all right so
um you want to get on the same page how
many of you have asked this question of
like okay so so can you show me a
roadmap your mind map
okay yeah when you're working with a
product partner always ask for this and
if they don't have one that's okay
that's okay just have them talk it
through with you and if you can start to
draw it out together use whatever tool
is at hand even that if that ends up
being pencil and paper because the thing
is communication is actually kind of
hard right the idea or the thought that
we have in in our heads doesn't always
necessarily translate when you're just
talking it through draw it out because
that way you'll be able to know that
you're seeing things the same way
so here's the here's the other piece
where you can bring your data expertise
is that insights from data are useful
inputs for the roadmap and so if you
have that information if if you you can
make that information available to your
PM your PM can know how to allocate
resources and then prioritize features
and then also they can make sure that
the roadmap is in line with corporate
goals or company goals
okay so
um here's another thing that you're
probably thinking about too is
understanding the customer so you want
to know who the customers are right
that's always a fundamental question and
sometimes those customers aren't
necessarily the uh in in Enterprise
software something that I discovered is
like sometimes those customers aren't
actually the user of the product it's
the buyer of the product I don't know if
you have any thoughts about like how you
discover what the buyer is interested in
or how they're but you might be able to
figure out how they're using your
product
and if you can bring those insights to
the product discussion again you can
start to help reshape and influence the
roadmap and also how how the business
moves forward
um you want to do things like bucketing
and segmentation you also want to if for
those of you who work in the world of
words right you also want to like user
feedback is really really useful and
again it's that thing of like what are
people what do people tell you that they
want you can pair that with how are
people actually behaving or trying to
behave
when you have that that sort of Fuller
picture you can start to say you know
what we you know we have some ideas for
how we might want to move forward
you want to improve that user experience
and then you also want to do a thing
that I call reduce suffering and
increase Joy
because a happy customer stays with you
it's less expensive to keep them right
and then you can continue to keep
growing
um and then the last thing I'll say here
with regard to understanding the
customer because you know it is a
business we always want to know how much
are people willing to pay and I bet a
number of you have experience right like
running the a b testing doing sort of
different Financial models right and
those are things that I feel like a you
know a good partnership right a good
partnership
bringing your expertise can really
really help Drive the product forward
and make sure that you have a very
strong alliance with your product
partner
okay so let's move on another aspect
with regard to working with a product
person is like you're gonna the product
people they might not say these words a
performance evaluation I find sometimes
uh the conversations end up being a lot
of like questions about like what are
people doing right
um what are the users doing and how many
of them are dealing it uh users all of
these like user engagement metrics right
become very very important fundamental
things that you can help
um you know bring as information as your
product person and your product partner
is thinking about like okay
I'm trying to increase adoption
growth retention and expansion so who's
using our thing right and what are they
doing with it how often and how long uh
they're going to be also looking for
things like conversion rates so are
people doing what we want them to do and
if not maybe there's an opportunity to
improve the improve the features improve
the experience or maybe sort of you know
change things up within the product
itself
um and then there's also customer
satisfaction how many of you work on
like the customer satisfaction side of
okay I see a couple of hands yeah
um customer satisfaction is like an
interesting really interesting space
uh and I think for those of you that
dive into it and think about again that
combination of utility and feelings
this becomes really useful uh yeah and
it's useful in a few different ways
because you you want to be tracking that
information all of the time
all right
so let's take a look into the future
so when it comes to looking into the
future one of the things I find really
fascinating about what you know working
with data you know data experts is is
like Predictive Analytics right so you
want to do things like estimate customer
demand you might want to also think
about like potential growth
opportunities and you also want to do
like optimizing resource allocation
so if you think about how you can look
forward and push into the future how you
want to optimize like the resources that
you have at hand like all of these
things are within your control and if
you partner well with your product if
you partner well with your product
counterpart right again this is how you
too can start to influence the product
so there's other aspects of looking into
the future that you might want to think
about and bring to the table too which
is a competitor analysis so there are
businesses that that take the stance it
doesn't matter what our competitor is
doing we just focus on the customer and
that's how we move forward
but honestly
like it's a it's a it is it is a
confidence stance but I'm not entirely
sure it's realistic because if you don't
watch what other people are doing
sometimes people you know sometimes a
competitor will surprise you so you
always want to keep your sort of like
you know ears open and you're you know
just like some general awareness even if
your internal culture and the company is
to not talk about competitors you still
want to know
so in doing competitor analysis you can
do things like research customer
preferences or consumer preferences and
market trends as well as competitor
products
you also might want to and knowing what
this is can help you better position
your products either to you know either
to compete Head to Head or do something
that was that you know to be a need but
hasn't been addressed in the market
before
um and then you know in in the end you
want to set yourself set yourself apart
from the competition but do in a way
that serves the customer as well either
the customers that you have or the
customers that you're trying to acquire
so
um with that you know this is uh one of
these this is kind of the as I was
thinking about how to write this talk
there's like a bunch of different
um things I was thinking about and I
didn't want to take up too much time so
I'm just going to wrap it up here and
say you know what there's uh what drives
final decision making it's really about
winning hearts and minds and you can do
that with data so if you have any other
questions please feel free to see me
after the conference or during the break
I was going to tell you some more
stories but I'll just keep that for like
hallway to chat
um but any case uh thank you
foreign